you'll never meet a hater doing better
than you tell me about this mixed type
of hate that you've made as you get
bigger as you get more successful you
open the door for people to critique
everything you do I started having fun
with it while most people don't go
through comments I go through them
intentionally look for the bad ones I
take a snapshot on my phone and I put it
in the archive so I started making these
mixtapes with all of these hate messages
about people talking it became such a
source of fuel that it was amazing
because I know why you hate me you hate
me because you're probably in the bed
right now you're probably an
underachiever you're probably somebody
who doesn't want to do anything with
your life so I make you question
everything about yourself I sometimes
played in the house and it sometimes
gets on Jennifer's nerves because I'm
sitting and listening to somebody talk
match on a loop about me and she's like
why do you do this it's half comical
it's half inspiring I'm actually
inspired by it